i like to party hello everybody
and welcome back to another episode of
the interwax podcast with your favorite
sister sophia and sistine stallone
you guys happy freaking new year i know
i keep saying that for every episode but
like
the time frame of these uploading is
kind of confusing maybe a little bit but
this is coming out soon
and we had a really fun new years we
were with family
we were in florida yes wow
my parents were in florida oh my god
yeah you're stressing me all right we
have someone off camera we're going to
bring in
the face about us right now we were in
florida um to visit our
parents lovely it was fun lovely it was
great
you guys know if you're a true listener
the true struggle that we have with
finding men today
um let me just tell you these florida
bred men
there was not a shortage of those men
it wasn't like a sound story so fast
sound
like the most desperate okay girls ever
no this is so funny so sophia and i
we're very big into exercise right we
love to go on our daily walks
we're walking along one day in florida
just enjoying the humidity
you see the ocean looks great it's
beautiful
the the gorgeous specimens
passing us by all running all athletic
to my right to my left constantly sophia
and i are full blown runners now
i have had many shin splints and i don't
care i'll keep going
i hate running i hate and now i run
simply so i can
meet cute a guy what are you saying
funny i told sistine this
i was on one of my runs kind of i was
run walking because i was getting winded
and a guy kept passing me on the bike
and he tagged me in a video when i got
home saying
hi somebody fracking which is kind of
odd he recognized me i'd like to touch
on that
i think that's really creepy i think
that's creepy
a stranger passes you by yeah you guys
don't even talk
no he knows who we're just giving each
other no no but he takes a video of the
walk
and then tags you in it because he
wanted me to know who he was that's
creepy hmm was it i think a little bit
i think it was a meat cute and it could
have worked but um
you're not my type sorry so we're back
in l.a yeah you can tell by our home
studio
and sophia you guys know i'm not really
big into the bachelor
never really been a huge fan i've always
been a fake bachelor person and i have
finally converted her not to converted
me
but converted our little special guest
off cam who is now our
roommate you guys we've been talking
about moving out
yeah we're talking about having a new
roommate this is it
his name is ryan he's from denver
he is our cousin he is six three three
[Applause]
yes did i make you watch the voucher
with us the other night yes do you enjoy
it
yeah it's pretty it's pretty good okay
so we now have a new monday night
tradition
sophia ryan i cigars wine
bachelorette why don't we uh talk about
our findings from the intro a little bit
from the intro oh with the girls that
came in yeah okay i think we realized
that
dresses do matter in terms of what color
they are
right which one was your favorite ryan
the intro of the girls walking in
i like well personally i like to grow in
a white dress
oh because it reminds you of
did you like any of the crazy intros
that they did one girl brought a
vibrator
oh yeah that was funny that was funny
the lingerie was funny the lingerie
we did that was a genius one yes because
then the guy got to choose like what
dress
he wanted to see yeah that's good is
that too s
is that too quick too soon definitely
caught his attention
does she stay yeah she says
we're excited because pretty soon all
three of us are um we're currently
looking for places it's been kind of a
hassle looking for an apartment
because you know it's during quarantine
it is uh i think things are not really
can we talk about how handsome brian
looks right now it just changes
business uh business professional what
are you talking about what you do ryan
uh i'm an insurance broker it's pretty
here we go
some
[Music]
yeah okay so sophia and i
again we're going to reiterate we love
to do our unsolicited advice segment
i'm gonna just you know recap or why
don't you do it for me
recap of how people can get their
questions answered
so you guys if you want questions
answered from us you have to go to the
ratings and review section on
apple podcast give us that five star and
write the question there
we will not answer anything if it's from
our dms
we do answer dms when it's positive
comments saying we love your show and
stuff because i heard people saying
i read some of the comments going oh
like we dm you don't respond to our
questions
you guys ratings and reviews that's the
only place we'll do it
because we also love reading your
questions as well so
i'd like to say i think i answered quite
a quite a good amount
of dms someone will ask me for my
lipstick combo i'll answer
yeah i mean i answer i think i do pretty
good someone asked me on a date
didn't answer it but i do appreciate i
do appreciate
the uh confidence you guys will
absolutely
love the guests that we have yeah today
i went to usc with her but she has
thrived in the space of mental health
and confidence and body image
and she is on every platform she's on
youtube instagram tick tock yeah it
really just goes conversation was so
cool it was all about
you know the beauty standards today it's
all about instagram and facetune
but also sistine knife get pretty
personal about some of the insecurities
and things we've gone through so
we hope you stick around and listen stay
tuned
all right oh ready three
two one stop laughing at me i can't like
do it
okay other than being one of the
sweetest humans alive
this former usc division athlete has
become a leader
in the mental health and body image
advocacy space
she speaks at colleges across the
country hosts her amazing
podcast realpod and is the founder of a
student athlete organization
destigmatizing
mental health it is called the hidden
opponent that's just
the surface of it and she's killing it
on tick-tock
[Applause]
i bring that up because i remember the
last time i saw or when we were at the
beach like months and months ago you're
like i gotta be tick-tock famous
well that was when it was like j i was
just getting into it and it's like
that craving for like a viral video it's
it's just
fun because you never know what's going
to hit but that was so that was just a
great intro sophia i need you to record
that as my alarm in the morning oh my
gosh that's why
i want to bring tone everything in your
life honestly how great would that be
just have a really big motivation
like speech to wake up to every day like
you're the best you're the hottest
you're the strongest
it's so funny you say that because i
made my alarm sound for like the past
month um superwoman by alicia keys
because i was like okay this is just
gonna be the best vibe
ever but the it ends up anything you
make your alarm you end up
not liking because i would just hear
that like
[Music]
i'm music and it like was now a
negativity so it's tough to find that
wait that's so smart though we have to
figure out some sort of alarm in our
life that just
reminds us that you are stupid that
could be a good business idea like an
alarm that changes
every morning and it's just like a
motivation alarm
yeah because if you get used to the
sound you're waking up to you
automatically despise it so yeah and
then you don't want to get out of bed
i mean count me as an investor perfect
let's do it oh my god this is amazing i
mean
you would if anybody i'd have you join
because you've literally i was saying to
cysteine
i have never seen someone that works
honestly harder than you and i know you
sometimes
like go like me no you seriously have
done
so much like i remember in college when
you were
starting out this kind of journey that i
almost kind of
honestly fell into it did you kind of
like fall into this hole because i
remember
not like the whole space of it because
you'd post little things here and there
like being a bit more real and authentic
yeah i would love for
if you could give like a little spiel to
our listeners like
how did you start and what exactly you
are pushing to promote today
definitely i'm happy to give this feel
and you were definitely on to it with
kind of what you just said
i kind of fell into all of this super
organically um you know there was never
a moment where i
was like how do i build a social media
platform and become
self-employed and like build rent never
happened for me
basically i went to usc just thinking
like i'm going to be a sports reporter
like i'm going to be in annenberg
classic like you know usd and a girl
um same here yeah nothing wrong with it
you know but like there's a lot of us
and i um quickly really started to
struggle whether it was like developing
anxiety
due to volleyball or just the body image
pressures i felt attending usc i don't
know if you guys can relate to that
everyone on the campus
we'll talk about that because we
definitely want to bring that up yeah it
is tense
um and so i just started to really not
be doing well at all
and at the same time i was kind of
putting up this facade on my instagram
that i was great and i was looking great
and life was good
and the long story short is i got to a
place that was so
kind of rock bottom for me with
depression and just
everything i've been going through and
that i kind of realized
um you know how was no one talking about
this and i started
to see like a lot of my friends are also
not well and we all post these pictures
and we all act like it's okay
and i kind of uh once i started to see a
therapist and
get help and get better i felt like
confident enough to be like this is not
okay
you know how did this happen to me how
does this happen to other people and
you know talk about it it's so
stigmatized and that's what kind of
inspired me to
deliver a ted talk at usc and from that
point on
is when like things really change i
didn't think
uh much of the ted talk obviously okay
that's
why i thought much of it come on that
was honestly when we all heard on campus
genuinely like that you did a ted talk
this girl was legit it was so cool
i definitely knew that was like a
significant deal but you have no idea i
mean you get
i knew the act of giving the talk was a
big deal it was months of prep
and i was really passionate about it but
then you wait like two months for it to
go on youtube like to me it felt over
like
i spoke but then it gets uploaded to
youtube and then it starts getting views
and i start getting messages and
i just kind of um and i had already been
kind of doing this
thing i called hashtag real post which
at the time was a joke like i
was posting uh just
i call it like it was my britney 2007
like moment you know like
i people were looking at my instagram
like concerned and i was like
this is just the new me it's just like
you look at girls at usc or just even in
college in general and they don't post
like instantly randomly stuff like real
posts
ever yeah i mean we'll get into that a
little bit more but yeah you had from
like
positive brittany not even clever
like real post like it's like so at the
time i was just like
solo like real post and then um people
started coming to my page from the ted
talk i had also written this
article on body image which the body
image article was like
a one-off a professor was like will you
write an article about title nine and i
sat down to write it and i was like i
don't
i was like this doesn't feel real to me
i'm dying to write about how i hate my
body
can i do that um i just like
talk about how much like i have like
insecurities and stuff just like people
sometimes it's easier to talk about what
you don't like about yourself well she
asked me to write an article about
female athletes like something for women
in sports day and she gave me the
subject of title
ix which is so important but i was dying
to write a different story which is the
female athlete body image issues i'd
experience
so i just wrote that instead and that
went viral and then like people started
coming to my instagram and
this is not like viral in the sense of
uh
overnight sensation not at all but just
like very slowly trickling in
100 likes to 150
i just started like well i have more to
say and i have more to share and so i
just kind of kept posting and then
senior year someone asked me to speak
somewhere and just kind of
went on from there history i know and
then you launched your podcast where you
talk to
athletes doctors kind of anyway i was on
it i don't even know how
i was like so nervous to be on it but
being really real and a lot of girls and
guys can relate to you and
i feel like the talk about body image
self love
mental health it's so still not talked
about enough
yeah and i feel like people it's really
hard for people to open up about it but
i know sister wanted to bring up
something
when did you so you started feeling
these
body insecurities around college was it
the perfect storm between seeing all the
girls at usc have these like perfect
zero frames
and also being a college athlete where
you're told you must lift this much and
you must gain this much weight and you
must
you know eat this many calories was sort
of just like the perfect storm of all of
it that you were like
this isn't what i want to look like yes
definitely it was a perfect storm
i also have to say growing up i
definitely have body image issues and
problems with food
but then this is all this like i and
using the word trauma for me
it's always hard for me to use that word
because you think of other people's
trauma and you're like well i can't call
this trauma in my privileged
white life like you know so i hesitate
to use that word but there were
things like growing up where i was like
uh you know really struggling with food
or on like these really harmful forums
and i was obsessed with being
in and at the time i thought that was
totally normal i was like oh it's normal
that i'm 14 and i'm having a slim quick
shake for lunch
um but then you grow up and you're like
that's not
not normal and i think i had grown up
kind of with disorderly eating habits i
counted the calories
but i had like been able to maintain and
it's kind of like
once i got to usc my regimen was so
different i was working out every single
day i was hungrier
i was not able to do the little diet
things i did in high school that just
like
totally yeah totally was that
the it was the storm of like the
pressure of usc
the two different body types i felt like
i had to have right there's the beauty
standard the one we see in like
uh mainstream social media and then
there's the body type of female athletes
which are just polar opposite
i didn't know where i felt um and i was
also really struggling to monitor
how much i was eating my appetite and i
had all this like internalized
uh you know fat phobia and disordered
habits that work
i feel like that's kind of something
that we've also related to i know she
you were the modeling industry well
yeah i just wanted to like touch on that
because i feel exactly
what you had felt or i did feel exactly
what you had felt because when i moved
to new york to model
i was like okay everyone around me is
way skinnier and i thought i was already
skinny as
and my agents were like well you need to
lose weight to get the job so i was like
okay they know better what do i know i'm
just a 19 year old kid and so i did
and i realized that that was my darkest
time i was the most unhappy but also
you know you growing up you know
drinking the
slim quick shakes and whatever and
having to force yourself to eat like an
athlete
it's like mentally it's really hard
because when i was moving back to la
i was like oh my god i have to train
myself to eat like a normal human being
again and
and making that transition was really
really tough so at what point did you
say
you know what like [ __ ] it like i don't
care what anyone thinks about my frame
i'm gonna do what i want was that in
college
um yes well okay so i have two things so
i have a thought on what you just said
because
first of all i think it's so cool that
you both are hosting this conversation i
think
that's a big deal and you guys might
think it's not but it is a big deal
because there's so many girls and women
who follow you guys and look up to you
and
i really appreciate like how candid you
guys are both thank you
the same for you thanks um
and yeah the judgment so like sistine
you mentioned like
the portion or like what how much you're
eating i mean you grow up looking at
like
um a guy's plate or like what is too
much or what a serving size is like
the recipient scars you with a cup of
pasta a cup of carbs i don't know it's
like you're
measuring yeah you're all like i know
and so then i'm like
whoa i feel like eating four cups of
carbs after that five
set game against stanford and then i'm
judging myself i'm like why am i eating
so much food
so that definitely resonates and then in
terms of like when things changed for me
it definitely was not an overnight uh
thing at all
um i would say the first thing that i
really had to
to change was my relationship with food
um and that for me started around
sophomore spurring um into junior year i
started intuitive eating
and that's basically an approach to food
that includes
rational thought um your emotions
satisfaction
into choices about what you want to eat
um and that was just mind-blowing for me
coming from years of diet culture where
it was never about what i wanted to eat
it was always about well how many
calories how many carbs
or like what's feminine what's not so
the thought of
i remember there's a sentence in this
book i read and it said it doesn't
matter if you want
if it doesn't matter if an egg white is
60 calories or 70
do you want an egg white and i was like
no
who wants it i'm sorry because that's
not even the question you asked myself
you know like it was always about
so i started to kind of approach food
with okay what's going to make me feel
good
if i can have everything i'm not going
to feel this need to binge
you know the chips at night which is
exactly yeah
that started naturally and then i think
i slowly started to really appreciate my
female athlete body like
i got to a point where i like loved
lifting heavy and i i saw that
my body was an instrument for me and it
wasn't just about it being an
ornament and um i slowly shifted my
focus and
it definitely takes you know hard work
and reps and it's about what you
surround yourself with and the content
you consume
um but you know i'd say gradually and by
the time i think i was a senior
i was like really confident with any of
the insecurities that
i would have been mortified to post yeah
freshman yeah
well touching on confident did you feel
like when you
started oozing this confident from
confidence from inside you that others
around you
started to believe it too because
sometimes you know i'll like fake it and
i'll pretend like i'm confident but i
really feel insecure and then when i
find that people gravitate the most
towards me is when
it's coming out genuinely so when you
started to fully accept yourself did you
see a switch and
sort of your peers around you yeah i
mean i think the craziest thing is
me being honest about my mental health
and that i wasn't okay
is the reason i've been able to build a
platform community that
is there today and it's just so
interesting to think about like
the moment i started being true to
myself and um
you know posting things that were real
that resonated with people and then i
became
i almost felt like more loved and
accepted and i heard this really cool
thing said on a doc shepard's podcast
once but he was saying how
when we're vulnerable and we talk about
our insecurities or things that aren't
well in our life
you know you can relate because
everyone's suffered and everyone's been
through things like that so when i
say i'm not okay someone can say oh well
well i haven't been okay either
whereas if i say oh my gosh um you know
we want a packed world championship
no one can say oh yeah well i did that
too like yeah
how you're gonna connect with others
it's being vulnerable and honest about
like
what you're going through and it's so
interesting to see celebrities who like
you know once in a blue moon a celebrity
will do like what i would call a real
post right like a no filter and a long
caption and
that always has the most engagement has
the most
it's funny have you ever seen love
island
okay so one of the girls more i saw her
post this like a couple weeks ago and
she has a pretty thin
frame and on social media she posted
her post food baby basically like her
belly blow which
we all have and like i definitely think
we all have felt insecure about
like why are we feeling so much bigger
but it's so normal
so she posted it and she literally
posted it again
saying she got thousands and thousands
of thousands of responses
from girls saying thank you so much for
showing me that
you two who has a size zero frame gets
this giant belly blow
that we all get and i think that that's
the problem is a lot of people
need that more i think a lot of people
that do i need the realness i think yeah
i think especially people that are
followed and i know that
i need to start doing that sometimes
well i i want to praise you and your
instagram you guys definitely need to
follow victoria
on instagram because what i loved i mean
i was stalking you hard i will admit
that proudly
what i loved about your instagram was
that in this perfectly
filtered edited world not only did you
post your facetune version but you
posted the real version
and then you also had a caption along
with it and then i mean it was
so nice to see something that was just
not touched
you authentically getting the same
amount of love that you probably
really love probably than you would have
gotten if you touched it
yeah and the thing is too if people
aren't ready to
reveal their insecurities like i don't
need people to show off
or show that they have uh roles or they
have stretch marks if that's
they're not comfortable with it yet but
at least don't post things acting like
you don't have that you know what i'm
saying like
well like if you're not in a place where
you can delete your face tune that's
fine i get it it's the patriarchy like
you're brainwashed i don't blame you
but if you have to facetune a picture to
post it
pick a different picture because then
you're contributing
because there are times i've looked at
the photo where i'm like okay this is
actually a pretty good photo
i put on face too and then i go almost
too ham on it where i look at them like
i don't look like the same person i went
so
in it with the details well the angle
there has to be some sort of like reveal
button and you're like
the before and after it's just and it
really and it actually makes me feel
worse about myself because i was just
gonna touch on that like there must
it has to be associated with you feeling
even more like [ __ ] because
if you're having to alter the way you
want to look in every single picture i
mean
long term that's going to affect
someone's mental health of course i mean
it affects the way you see yourself
and i mean i was it i had a point in my
life where nothing
didn't go through facetune before i went
to my instagram like everything did
um the point where like family pictures
i needed like my dad to send me the one
file that we were gonna post and like i
had to edit it
first like just insane and you know
to anyone who's going through that like
i just think if you're not ready to
delete the app
just slowly start by trying to only
upload pictures where you don't need to
do the retouch
and just slowly baby steps and i don't
like to
berate or tease anyone who does facetune
because it's just that it's just
insecurity like
it's true it's true kelly kardashian
photos it's just like
i saw someone say how we shouldn't bully
her
and you know condemn her for what she's
doing obviously it's not right but she's
also been called
ugly sister and she's been bullied for
years like
yeah the fact that maybe she wants to
tune her face here
totally no you know it's just i think
baby steps is the best way to start kind
of i couldn't agree more
i remember when i when instagram first
came out i think it was 15
and facetune came right after that i
mean i remember i would
smooth my face so much that the filter
the camera looked out of focus
i remember that but then baby steps
you're so right
i don't use face tune out if i have a
blemish yeah i'll take it out because
i'm not proud of that blemish i don't
want people to see a blemish
but i used to really you know i would
post a phone or take a photo and i'm
like oh my god i hate the way
my arm looks huge in this picture but
then i realized i'd go to bed thinking
hmm no one is going to wake up the next
day
that saw my picture and it's going to
say yeah sistine's arm would look pretty
chunky
and like no one's going to so you're
right baby steps it's always like all
about kind of reminding yourself
that do what makes you feel good and
don't pose for the satisfaction of other
people
yeah and along with that too is like you
know you mention the chunky arm like
i've really tried to take
those steps of like well what's wrong
with a chunky arm like you know what's
wrong with benchmarks or cellulite and
just kind of questioning
who and where down the line dictated
that we had to have this perfectly
smooth skin
and that one size body was a socially
acceptable and another one isn't it
really changing the people i follow
online i'd say
i want to say the majority of people i
see on my feed
are of all different body types and it's
really just
uplifting to to see that content
and start to kind of work on that beauty
standard that
has been ingrained oh my god i'm so glad
you said that because i
i wanted to touch on this up upon me
stalking you
like a creep last night um you posted a
picture
and it was a photo of a model in a
bikini with the caption
this picture makes me feel bad about my
body versus a picture of a beautiful
sized woman
and you said this picture makes me feel
like my body's enough
and then you wrote notice who you choose
to follow and how their content makes
you feel
and i could not agree with that more
because when i was feeling
really down about myself my mom told me
she goes to see
unfollow all of these victoria secret
models that you're trying to be
all of these you know kendall jenner's
ever it's like it's not gonna happen and
that's okay
so do you think that's a way for people
to sort of
you know out of sight out of mind is
that they should just unfollow girls
that make them feel bad
internally uh well definitely i think
you know you have to curate a fee that's
uplifting you know i think the important
thing to mention
along with that story is i did have some
people being like you know
it's not like everyone has the right to
post picture of their body yeah yeah
but you also have the right if there's
certain content that brings up old
emotions for you or is triggering that
you don't have to follow it
um so i think that's super important and
then something else
um oh i just had a good point what was
it christine you said
you were i looked actually
what was it that i don't follow people
oh yeah no i thought of it so you
mentioned the victory secret models
which
uh just like hit such a belt for me i
mean i couldn't when i was
this is so embarrassing when i was 15
legit
all the angels their heights their waist
measurements
who was wearing the fantasy bra like i
knew it oh yeah are you
me i tried out for them that's how much
i wanted it i mean
yeah but i gotta go but that's okay it's
okay
i really yeah i think that's probably
for the best and and honestly
um what one of the bigger things i i
realized too that really helped me kind
of accept
just who i am is i think we as
females are like kind of put in this
race or this wheel to like
become the prettiest and we've seen this
in like snow white you know who's the
fans of them all like growing up it's
always
who's the most pretty i mean reading the
twilight books and the way they
described
rosalie cullen i was like i want to rock
into a a lunch cafeteria and have
everyone look at me because i'm with the
wind blowing in your hair
[Music]
see beauty portrayed and i kind of got
to questioning it's like
that isn't real there's not a person
who we unanimously agree is the most
beautiful
you name a girl and someone else says
nope it's her nope not the type for me
nope i don't like the i
whatever it is no one's agreeing and so
when you kind of realize like
there's not a body type face lip size
hair color
that you could get to where everyone's
gonna be like
you're the most beautiful i mean it
doesn't exist no everyone has their own
type i mean you look at
everyone has like their own person they
are attracted to or a look that they are
more into but it's all about just almost
you're not perfecting but really being
the best version of yourself you can be
the healthiest version the happiest
version
because i know you also wrote one time
like about
happiness doesn't equal success or i was
something about that i
could you for like talk about that i was
basically
uh really struggling a few weeks ago
with
this need to achieve um sometimes i get
caught up with
people who are doing things similarly to
me and i'm like oh my gosh well am i not
doing enough is my not as
great as theirs getting as many follows
or listens and it's just it is
superficial and
um you know but i am i say it out loud
because i think it's common things that
we all struggle with is that need for
more and
you lose sight of like what's really
important and um basically what i was
trying to say in that caption
was it's okay to strive for
achievement right it's okay to push
yourself to be better
but you can ex you can't not allow
yourself to be happy now
you can't say the happiness only starts
when i get x y z the happiness has to
start now
and cool you can try to get x y z you
got to be happy with or without it
and i completely agree that because i
know that even sometimes we're like are
we
like are we at the right place in our
life like are we supposed to be
like we look i sometimes i follow really
like sometimes successful people that
are
younger just entrepreneurs i'm like oh
my god they are working
all the time they're making so much
money they're traveling the world and
they're so
young am i doing enough and i get really
hard on myself and you realize
everyone has their timeline no one
is on a certain path all at the same
time like no one is behind no one is
farther
i mean it's obviously the time we put
into it it's where you are in life like
you could have a different circumstance
than someone else
but in the end like where you are
10 years from now won't make you feel
better than what how you feel now it's
all going to be the same it's just
really
kind of manifesting and working towards
feeling the best
at that moment yeah we pick at different
times and also another thing that's been
really helpful with dealing with
those similar thoughts is there's room
for everyone
we think that if one girl does
x that no one else can do that ever and
there's just
tons of different creators there's tons
of different podcasters tons of
different
influencers and non-profits and uh
organizations and tv shows and yeah and
for people who have all different things
to say and share and
you know even when people talk about
getting into the podcast industry or
starting to build their brand like it's
just it's never too late i think there's
room for everyone and
that's why i think it's been really cool
to see especially women
working together and empowering each
other i certainly came into usc with a
bit more of a like
um i'm gonna feed myself before i feed
someone else
and it's completely for me by the people
who've helped me um and really showed me
that way
can i also just commend you for being so
honest and vulnerable especially on
social media yeah
we are going along the lines even just
like mental health
i remember you posted something like a
couple of days ago of you just like
i think tearing up or crying about
something and you're just like this is
how i'm feeling right now
dog tick-tock yeah it was like tick-tock
or something you were just like
upset and i'm like oh my god i'm the
things i post on social media
99 of the time i'm not like it's just
like fluffy it's fluffy
oh it's my highlight reel it's not my
actual you have to be nice to yourself
you guys because
not everyone has to post not every like
you don't have to share i guess
something i always tell people is
you don't have to tell the world your
mental health story if that's not
your healing yeah yeah like you know
don't
beat yourself up about like oh i'm not
able to post my most
insecure picture i mean i don't know oh
i know i know
but it was funny because he even posted
something that i was laughing about
you're like
it was like seven o'clock in the morning
today it's like
i wasn't the on because i had 10
seconds of being like this is actually
hideous i could not post this and i was
like
[ __ ] it so she goes [ __ ] it i was like
oh god
because the things i was thinking about
myself i know you're totally right like
if i don't want to post about my
anxieties this is enough i don't have to
um but i do realize the more i do talk
about things that i
am insecure about or i'm worried about i
get a lot of responses i'm very positive
i would love to touch on the responses
how has the feedback been
since you've you know posted your yawns
and your crying moments i mean
did you lose some following because of
it or did it just skyrocket a whole new
audience for you
well this is like rewinding back to the
very beginning
i certainly uh definitely was not
getting likes i mean
when i i mean and this is we're talking
like i had three thousand followers on
instagram just a normal college girl and
um you know of course you go from
posting like your bikini pictures
to like i said my just you know
real post coffee shop trees outside like
it was
i went total 0 to 100. of course those
weren't getting likes or comments and
like i said people were like this is
kind of weird what's wrong with victoria
um because everyone at usc is like
posting
them at game day in their little outfits
all the time i mean like that's what it
is like
and then you might want to get off the
rail
you know what was crazy about this have
you guys ever been like let's talk game
day like have you ever gone to an event
where
you could not be happy until you got the
grand
like i'm talking you could not even
enjoy um yeah
and talk about events in general like
we've had times where we've
had to sit down in a chair for like
three hours
i'll take it i'll take it a step further
i'll be upset if i'm wearing a cute
outfit and i couldn't just to go nowhere
and i couldn't get a photo like my day
is ruined i've trained so hard
no i haven't said i was just like
i didn't even enjoy the game day because
i was like
i haven't gotten the picture and every
party when i was like making my friend
take
hundreds of pictures of me and then i
like it was just and that was an
obsession to me like i couldn't even
enjoy
so i started to be like i'm gonna dress
up really cute i'm gonna feel myself
right and i'm not getting a picture
tonight you are lucky if you get to
witness me in the flesh
this is not being documented if it's
live that is yes
i know the full show i had to really
like that
addiction to the perfect instagram was
real for me at the time
right no it really is and sometimes we
get caught in that wave and honestly
sometimes today i am still addicted to
the good instagram and then i have to
smack myself out of it
who cares really i think some one
important thing that people need to
remember is to kind of self-check
because there's so many habits that i
used to do in the past i was like
even with food i would not have
something because i know okay an apple
is 80 calories this is this many
calories
i've started to calorie i'm like wait a
minute why am i doing that and then i
have to rewind take some
i'm like i'm having an apple or the
photo over editing i'm like
i don't need to do that or that's why i
love disposable cameras you can't touch
them
like unless you upload it and then you
do it but like
there are times where we need to go back
and go okay
let's enjoy the moment let's have fun at
game day like we only have four years of
this
like less drink a beer get the belly
button it's okay
life will go on and that's i think
that's the point of life is just enjoy
it enjoy your body and enjoy
that photo the time with your friends
like don't over
analyze it and be so hard on yourself
because everyone else is feeling the
exact same way
if someone doesn't feel like that please
let me know how it's happening
and if you were to scroll back on your
instagram
when you're 70 which is so weird to
think about unless we all hear like
it's your victoria garrick 40 plus
account like i don't know do you switch
accounts when
yeah who knows
350 whatever it's called like changing
it up
when you scroll back i mean i just
remember looking at my feed and then
looking at my life and being like these
are two completely different things and
i don't want to
like i've done i haven't documented the
truth and you know
just thinking about the moments that
really are gonna matter to you and the
pictures that really matter to you and
you know just i remember thinking about
like i didn't ever post with family
members or like
maya because i didn't look good in the
picture
and it's just so like you know so
ridiculous it's so silly but it's it's
good that we're having these
conversations now
and we're all still really young and i
hope a lot of people out there
can you know start to do it today
because at the end of the day it's like
we only have one life
don't stress about what an instagram
looks like they may look at you and they
may think okay victoria had like it's
from two different sides they may look
at us who don't talk about
body image or mental health that often
be like oh they have it all together
they're perfect and they may look like
you and go she's so open about it and
she's so herself
that she has it all together we're it's
dave you know what i'm saying like we're
both in the same position
no happy meetings it's not like this
that's my stream
so excited to have this conversation
with you guys because
you know it is really cool to
hear and it's so funny that like we ran
in similar circles at usc but we never
really crossed paths until after
graduation
even though my best friend is dating
your brother
i know but even from the outside like
looking in on someone's life you just
think oh they must have it all
yeah and that's never the case well our
listeners
asked a few questions if you could so
kindly answer because they were really
excited to have you on
so this one says hi victoria i am an
athlete too and i am constantly having
this battle with my head and my body
i want to have a petite frame slash
build but i also train lift and eat like
an athlete
what do you think is the best way for me
to be okay with how i look and accept it
love you aw
love you too great question you know
i think the biggest thing is really
shifting your mentality to what your
body is
doing for you as opposed to how it looks
for you
and you know there are actionable ways
you can
start to live that you know it's hard to
just think oh i'm going to care more
about my body does but
when i was a volleyball player and i had
a very similar situation if i want to
look one way but my body's changing
i made the adamant decision i'm not
gonna look in our full-body mirror in
the locker room
i'm gonna put on my spandex i'm gonna
put on my shirt and i'm just gonna walk
to the door and go to the practice gym
ex-nay on the five-minute stare down
and the gap and my butt looking flat
whatever it was it's not going to do it
because that's not my priority anymore
and so you know my advice would be
finding small ways to
really start to appreciate what your
body is doing for you
and and keep prioritizing how it looks
that's a great great answer
i'll read the third one awesome um i
just started dating someone whose last
girlfriend was thinner than me
i'm still insecure about my body when
i'm around him how can i let my guard
down and be fully confident with who i
am when
i'm around him which i think is so funny
because i i feel like i've had those
same moments where i'm like
oh god like something doesn't feel good
he's gonna notice that and
it just makes you feel sometimes less
than when the guy really doesn't
i don't think that's the thing is i mean
it sounds like he's dating her
sounds like you guys have a good reason
right he didn't say like he makes
comments
so he from what you know what reading
the room here
he loves you he must think you're
beautiful and he wants to be with you
and i think that you know should comfort
you that feeling of knowing and
i also think too like the comparisons to
the ex-girlfriend and the amount of
conversations that people have about the
ex the accidents like always
let that girl live laughs
like all the time i hear friends being
like oh my god you see what his ex is
doing i'm like you're dating him now
it's totally okay you guys focus on you
gosh i think
you know that relationship must have
ended for a reason it's clear he wants
to be with you
and you know and if ever it did get to a
point where you felt like you wanted to
have a conversation i'm like i'm a huge
believer in
you need to have hard conversations with
the people you're in a relationship with
and if you don't feel like you can have
the conversation maybe
take a step back and question how far
along this
is i i always tell i told sistine last
night that i love
your and max's relationship just because
of how like
honestly open you guys are i love it too
it's so cute it's great it seems so like
i mean obviously i've hung out with you
guys multiple times like in person and i
can still see that it's like the same
online as it is in person but it really
is something like i even strive towards
is
being that comfortable with someone it's
like genuine love
with that person he loves you for you he
doesn't love you for anything else like
no matter
who you are like he just loves your body
your mind
your kindness it's it really is
something to strive for in a
relationship
yeah and i wish i could say i mean a lot
of the
oh a lot of the um initial growth i had
with my relationship with myself was
definitely
totally me but i would be lying if i
said it wasn't a huge
help to have a boyfriend who like
doesn't care if you don't shave your
legs and
doesn't ever make comments on your i
mean that side max knows it's like
sensitive for me so he would never
um that's the thing this is
communication like i've told him you
know
i never want him to say like if he says
what do you want for dinner i'm getting
chicken and i say
oh can you can you give me a pizza a
side of fries i want the milkshake and i
want this like
no comment that's my order you know
because he knows that any sort of like
wow that's a lot of food like that's
sensitive
yeah yeah i'm very most wanted i even
finished what i food but
my safety is having the option of the
food
um so you know what's that's so smart
because i i just like had this thought
right now and
there are so many people that say and
this is true to
be so confident relationship pretend you
have nothing wrong like you just own it
but we're human and sometimes there's
things in our body that
does trigger like i know that sistine
knows some of the things that she says
it to me or if i say to her
it will like set us off and it really
does hurt our feelings more than maybe
the other person
but that's the important thing in a
relationship is to
honestly if that if it's something that
really does trigger you
say it yeah you don't have to be a
hundred percent confident strong i think
it
also has to do with the fear of well if
they know what i really am like and know
what the kind of food i like maybe they
won't love me
so it's like cancelling that idea that
is it honestly you will say that if you
have something
you don't want others to know it's
because you feel that with that
knowledge you would no longer be free of
love
totally oh my god well victoria this
conversation
was so necessary it was one of those
conversations that
you know every once in a while you need
to tune up i needed this tune up i'm so
excited for our listeners to like hear
it
and love you and if the listeners out
there for the unwax podcast if you guys
want this conversation to continue
victoria plug where they can find your
podcast your socials everything
oh my gosh thank you well i i've really
enjoyed this time it's been so fun
chatting with you guys
my instagram is just victoria garrick my
podcast is called realpod and you guys
can stream my episode with sophia
we need to make a difference yes wait
put your tick tock put your ticks on
don't forget my kickback is victoria
garrick iv
there we go thank you so much for being
honest and open and vulnerable with us
thank you you are so unwaxed we love you
yes we got really unlocked today
oh my god well thank you for coming on
we'll see you soon hopefully bye guys
bye